um do you know about this controversy
i'm outraged by her getting
[ __ ] cancelled but okay so ridiculous
but well i mean she's fighting back
she's she's teaming up with
yeah she's kind of well yeah she's
fighting back
what is she doing she's doing a movie
with ben shapiro yeah his company
about her life right i think it's about
her life or just maybe something that
she's
she's wanted to do far cry from
mandalorian but good for her
you know it's not star wars it's not
disney here's what gets a little dicey
is even when she did all this tweets
which some of them and whatever if you
want to be political be political
the nazi one with corona little extreme
but i don't know if she should be firing
but a little extreme i didn't find it
it was a clumsy it might have been a
clumsy comparison
but all she was saying is that a lot of
these
things start with snitching on your
neighbor yeah and that's not good for
unity it's not and i agree with her
here's the problem though so then disney
knows all this then she had the
transgender thing but then she even went
back on that apologize she's like i
didn't realize i was offending people
by putting my pronouns our bebop boop
you know she was like
oh she's making you know yeah and she
goes oh i talked to a transgender friend
and they let me know that's not okay i
apologize
so whatever she apologized but then with
this stuff disney was like hey man
if you're gonna stay on you need to
apologize and she refused to do a
uh apology that's when they fired her
but i i
yeah again i wouldn't have apologized
because i don't know what she has to
apologize for she made a reference to
the holocaust she wasn't
belittling jews she she wasn't
belittling the culture she wasn't
belittling her
religion at all she was saying that if
she has a point of view on this which is
that
some of these these government policies
are
are uh oppressive or are uh
authoritarian
historically a lot of these things do
start this way i'm not saying
i'm not saying i even necessarily agree
i'm just saying it's a clumsy comparison
but to fi
i think you know what i should lose i
think she lost her job for her
i think sometimes i think they're
waiting to fire yeah and they're like
all right yeah oh
she did what and people are upset
sometimes they go you know we have a
we want to go take the story a different
place we want a different actress oh
so it's like yeah i think so but it's
also
her [ __ ] co-star who is very
left-wing uh
po what's his name the other guy he
posted something
exactly like pedro pascoe he was on game
of thrones yeah in 2018 he
[ __ ] tweeted something way more
clumsy he
competed tweeted a uh a [ __ ]
holocaust reference where he had kids in
cages
at the border yeah and then he had
concentration no one cared
now that's now those kids comparing
those kids and it's
terrible that they're they're taken away
from their parents you don't compare
that
it's not comparable to jews who were
starved tortured well none of it's
comparable just don't compare
none of it but that's really cool he
didn't lose his job
nothing yeah he's celebrating so you
think they wanted her because he's on
because he's on that
side of the spectrum no we live in a
time if you she's the trump supporter
got it well you know if you so they want
to cancel anyone who's if you're a trump
supporter and you're in hollywood
it's no secret if you're a trump
supporter and you're anywhere now
it's no secret she wouldn't know that
you're gonna lose your job she knew she
had to know that there was gonna be some
background some background so i'm
thinking
yeah yeah yeah no there's gonna be
consequences of repercussions but now
dana's in trouble because what because
so he's not necessarily in trouble but
uh he said something like in defensive
he said leave gina alone
and then and then dana's argument is
because they would ask ariel who's
espn that's where the story is he goes
oh this whatever
that kid's a douche yeah because he's
trying to make it about himself that's
right arrow did this post a very long
post on his instagram
i'm with dana on this i'm with daniel
what ariel said like you know
he he's disappointed gina yeah he made
his my huge
jews and all this is like this isn't
valuable hey ariel
yeah this ain't about yeah it's not
about him you don't need to tweet about
every single jewish thing
this isn't about you yeah and he's also
in the world too so
you're just dog piling on gina the
interview she's giving you and [ __ ] it's
like what are you doing
so dana didn't say he didn't mention
about his jewish heritage
he just goes i get kids a douche
basically yeah and if you know the
background between dan and errol they
don't like each other so
of course they just take a shot at him
yeah and then all the so
the you know the wokiest being like
we're like oh dana should be fired and
good for you ariel say oh god get out of
here yeah ariel ariel
does great a lot of fighters the wrong
way i mean ariel is
he's a lot of people get mad at him yeah
yeah yeah cause he's a reporter that
wants to get he's also a good
i mean ariel toby ferris is pretty good
journalist i mean pretty good mma
journalist i would say i mean you know
but a lot of people don't like them
because yeah the video calls you on
stuff oh just that so this is just him
saying
because he's saying that ariel is making
it about him and it kind of does seem
like he does make it about him too but
of course he's also very offended by
what happened too
but i'll play this clip remember dana it
wasn't that offensive i'm sorry
for everybody go in on her i love how
era huani made it all about him
it was all about him yeah such a douche
yeah that's it oh that's awesome but
again that he's not anti-semitic he's
not anti-he's anti-aerial he hates areas
and i think there's an argument to be
made there i think he's kind of a lot of
people
don't like ariel you look at ariel's uh
tweet like geez dude
don't be hey hey era you don't have to
you don't have to beat it
don't dog pile she already got [ __ ]
okay right [ __ ] over big yeah you're
not helping anyone
yeah you're definitely just your
colleagues at espn gave you the raw rob
but that's about it yeah you're not
winning anything
they have to do that too well you know i
interviewed uh this guy aleister
bostwick who who is a journalist and
he's a journalist at huffington post
at buzzfeed very liberal kind of things
and i said to him i go
if you had a story that if you had one
story that
say was positive about trump so if you
said took one thing like i don't know
let's say
you took something like trump's
deregulation policies
and you could make an argument that they
were good for economic business
for some businesses or for certain um
segments of the
economy can't write it they're good for
like you know and he said i would get
green lit
but this is what happens what's going on
with our media it would get greenlit
your editor's not gonna say you can't
write it the problem is are they gonna
promote it yeah are they gonna put it on
the front page
how is it gonna be for you when you come
back to work the next day yeah when all
your colleagues
are cutting their eyes at you yeah and
how long can you sustain that
if you're the one guy that's trying to
like if you're just trying to tell the
truth
yeah if you're trying to go let me let
me see if i can come up with middle
ground there's
some things i like about the right
something's the left i like about the
left you got to be all or one
when you work for the huffington post
when you work for boston
the problem with that is that now now
when the buzzfeed writes something or
fox news writes something or breitbart
writes something i already know what
their agenda is i know i know what the
conclusion so i got to read everything
from the right or the left with a grain
of salt
because you there's too much pressure on
a journal so it used to be you came and
the whole thing was to write objectively
right
you you wrote you're trying to be
responsive to evidence
and you go here's this and here's that i
i it's it that's a big
that's what i also worry about yeah i
don't know where to look where do you
get your info
should i just read it all over all over
that's what i do all over all over
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son